so let's get this out of the way now no
I'm not that great a call of duty and no
it's not my go to multiplayer game sadly
I can't tell you about the intricate
tweaks made for the latest map designs
for the minor differences in the recall
of an assault rifle what I can tell you
though is that not having really enjoyed
or play the heck out of a Call of Duty
game as much as I did the original
modern warfare I was pleasantly
surprised by advanced warfare the fun it
seems is back in cards but then how
could a game featuring jet packs and
laser-guided smart grenades possibly not
be fun that's why I liked it so much
advanced warfare is as far removed from
the harsh realities of actual war as Cod
has ever been it's futuristic tech may
be based on some real-world visions of
the future but no matter how much it
tries to instill some realism to
proceedings I'm still relief rolling
around in a city strapped to an
exoskeleton it's the stuff sci-fi dreams
and made of most fun for me was the
multiplayer mode uplink here in a
strangely endearing cross between
basketball and classic team deathmatch
your team is tasked with grabbing a
satellite and placing it in the
opposition uplink to score points yes
where we will want all debating the
moral implications of modern warfare
two's no Russian level and being pelted
with Churchill quotes upon death now
we're doing something as daft as having
to slam dunk a satellite ball into a
floating orb of light while trying to
avoid being shot staff though it may be
it is a hell of a lot of fun if someone
grabs the satellite they are marked on
screen causing a mad dash of soldiers
either trying to steal the satellite or
protect the person holding it on smaller
maps like the excellent retreat having
that many soldiers all bunched up in one
place resulting quite a massacre but I
found getting up high and picking off
people amongst the madness worked
wonders for netting if you he kills
getting hold of the satellite was even
better you can't use weapons while it's
in your possession what you can do is
throw the ball around to other members
of your team to take it off even more
fun is throwing the ball to the
opposition which results in an instant
catch giving you ample opportunity to
waste them before picking up the ball
and running off again the other modes I
played hardpoint and Kill Confirmed
didn't have quite the same absurd appeal
as uplink
although Kill Confirmed certainly had
its moments more impressive was the
upgrade system pick 13 which takes its
inspiration from black ops pick 10
mechanic I've always found the upgrade
systems in cob games a little chaotic so
the simplicity of pick 13 is appealing
you're given 13 points to spend on your
avatars loadout and having everything in
one place including upgradeable
scorestreaks
just makes the whole system that much
easier to understand and to tweak loot
drops earned by completing challenges
made the game that little bit sweeter
too sure I might not have been top of
the leaderboard but thanks to loot drops
I still got some cool gear including a
neat warmus recoil free I am are
lightweight rifle that seemed perfect
for those with a less than steady hand
as with a single player sadly we didn't
get any capture of that but there is
supposedly a renewed focus on character
development this time around and one
hopes the inclusion of the mighty Kevin
Spacey has resulted in a deeper
narrative then again what would the
holiday season be without a stream of
brainless one-liners and an unbelievable
amount of clothes shade with a crashing
helicopter but it was the sheer fun of
the multiplayer that really sold
advanced warfare to me
for the first time in a long while I
think I'm actually looking forward to
this year's card